good morning good morning president Sall
of a Provost Pollock Dean Pollard
secretary golf crews chaplain Coogler
masters deans and honored guests and
welcome women and men of the class of
2017
welcome
welcome to Yale University and welcome
to Yale College I'm well all of us we're
so excited to have you here we've been
thinking about you since April when the
Dean of Admissions told us your names
then we met some of you during Bulldog
days we met a few more of you this week
in orientation programs but at last
class of 2017 you are here welcome
inside the walls onto the playing fields
into the classrooms and the residential
colleges welcome welcome to the spaces
and places you will soon call home and
welcome to all the families and friends
who have brought you to this day you've
come from Berlin Connecticut and Berlin
from Guadalajara to grinev out to
guangzhou from Tokyo and Topeka thanks
for having helped 1360 of the world's
most interesting and smartest young men
and women find their way to today we are
going to have exceptional encounters
with them over the next few years in the
classroom the dining halls intramural
fields in extracurricular activities let
me add that we plan to have plenty of
fun along the way but 2017 back to you
you have arrived at a campus that
witnessed an amazing transformation last
year when the Yale University Art
Gallery reopened after more than a
decade of rethinking what a museum and
particularly a university museum should
be like in the 21st century it is now a
complex of buildings that hold a vastly
expanded compendium of some of the
world's most remarkable and famous works
of art the media went wild over the new
museum and now people come from all over
the world to see the amazing collection
of things for which the maker
to the task trained in his or her craft
resulting in extraordinary outcome and
which are imbued with meaning each
painting each sculpture each thing in
the art gallery exemplifies what Paul
clay said art does not reproduce what we
see rather it makes us see yet here's an
astonishing number most art historians
and i am one would estimate that 99% of
all such works ever made are lost to us
ninety-nine percent some are
deliberately and willfully destroyed for
economic political religious and
personal reasons from tapestries burnt
to yield their gold and silver threads
to the implosion of the giant Buddha's
of Afghanistan to the recent rumor of
impressionist paintings burned to cover
the tracks of Thieves those objects have
been part of the one percent to survive
and now they are lost to us forever but
even without such human intervention the
survival of powerful charismatic works
is a dicey matter fires floods and most
of all time itself do their damage
especially given that most works on
canvas or paper or made of wood or
fabric are perishable or fugitive left
to the elements works of art vanish
often leaving no trace so it is not
surprising that most of the objects I
study from the pre-hispanic past of
Mexico and Central America are those
that were made of fired clay or stone
the two most enduring materials humans
have ever worked you have a picture in
front of you might want to take it out
have a look you have a picture in front
of you of an object that is on display
now at the Yale art gala
although as I will explain in just a
minute it is in fact part of the Peabody
Museum collection across campus it's an
Aztec carving from just about the time
of the Spanish invasion of Mexico in
1519 images of this sort were made much
of last December at the time that the
Maya calendar was reaching what
Hollywood and the tabloids in the
checkout aisle commonly called the Mayan
apocalypse but let me set you straight
no ancient maya ever used such an image
its Aztec you look at the picture in
front of you and you immediately
recognize that you're looking at an
image of the Sun its rays shooting out
from a nearly perfect circle this carved
stone came to rest in new haven in 1887
when something called the Aztec fair a
knockoff of more popular traveling
carnival pageants like Buffalo Bill's
Wild West Show came to town only to go
bankrupt here the saleable assets were
auctioned at a sheriff sale where the
founding director of Yale's Peabody
Museum purchased it and about a decade
later he gave it to the museum although
almost all Aztec works of the period of
which this comes from had been destroyed
especially the figural ones thought to
be at the heart of Aztec religion a few
fortunate but battered stone sculptures
did survive often because they were
useful the great calendar stone a much
larger version of a work closely related
to the one you are looking at was set
face down in mexico city's main square
to serve as a convenient paving stone
for 250 years only through deep
excavations in the past few years have
archaeologists at the city center begun
to recover a small corpus recovering
or Aztec works recently than in the
previous 450 years the survival of the
stone in front of you is a token of both
serendipity and durability what does the
stone itself say it claims that the four
previous eras of the earth have ended in
disaster in which the Sun collapses and
humans all vanish each era named by the
four dots and a glyph at the corners
starting in the upper left and moving
counterclockwise for Jaguar when jaguar
Marauders hate the Sun causing an earth
ending eclipse for wind when hurricanes
destroyed the world and blue humans into
trees turning them into monkeys for
water when floods annihilated the earth
and for rain when a volcanic reign of
fire brought the earth to an end the
sign at the center is of movement the
name of the era for movement in which
the Aztecs lived an era predicted to end
in earthquakes which would cause the Sun
to fall and to collapse for all eternity
quite honestly it's message is audacious
for it's an Aztec cosmos sustained by
human sacrifice that keeps this fifth
son in place held up by the starry
heavens marked along the four sides one
more battered bit this carved stone
served at the Aztec fair in 1887 as
backdrop to a story an entertainer
recounted to the citizens of New Haven
of how a captured prisoner became a
gladiator tied to the stone fending off
all comers but refusing to join his
Aztec captors having survived some four
hundred odd years before arriving at
Yale the Aztec stone was put on view at
the old peabody museum then located at
the corner of elm and high streets now
the home of sabor college saybrook isn't
here right now but i think they will
enjoy finding this
out I like to imagine that it might have
been on view right about where the
kitchen of the Masters house now is and
so the stone and I who served as master
of Sabre college for a decade spent ten
years in the same space a hundred years
apart the Aztec stone also survives the
1907 collapse of part of the old Peabody
when reportedly a number of exhibits
were destroyed the new Peabody the
current one would open in 1925 now just
one year ago the stone came to the Yale
art gallery for its new exhibition of
pre-columbian art the page you have in
front of you is from the 1910 article by
Yale anthropologist George Grant mccurdy
he had spent six years working his way
through a teacher's college in Missouri
and after a stint of teaching and
serving as a school superintendent he
found his way to Harvard Harvard
where he had to earn another bachelor's
degree in order to pursue graduate work
in biology and zoology he then became a
curator at the Peabody Museum with a key
role in its educational mission with
interests that ranged from the Aztecs to
the ancient andes mccurdy focused his
attention by and large on the origins of
mankind his 1924 book human origins is
now a fossil of its own mccurdy died
before the earliest hominids would be
recognized in Africa but he would play a
role in the opening exhibition at the
Peabody that sent shockwaves across the
United States in the wake of the Scopes
Monkey Trial in the summer of nineteen
twenty five in which the state of
Tennessee had successfully prosecuted a
public school teacher for teaching
Darwin's theories the Peabody would open
a few months later with an exhibition
that displayed human evolution
descending from great apes in a full
commitment to science and education the
Aztec stone was hardly noted in the
hubbub that followed but the art gallery
has now given the Aztecs stone a
featured setting and it gives us a new
way to enter a lost belief system in a
new context it takes on a new life
because of where it is not only among
other works from Mexico but also now
among the one percent of exceptional
things works of art to survive gathered
into one building these works that bear
and intensity of compression like a poem
like a mathematical formula any of these
things a work of art a verse a formula
compresses vast amounts of information
and thought as well as history your task
your opportunity here at Yale and in
life is to stop to screen out all other
distractions so that you can investigate
discover and interpret each one in light
of your understanding emulate this verse
from the poem where does the temple
begin where does it end by Mary Oliver I
look morning tonight I am never done
with looking looking I mean not just
standing around but standing around as
though with your arms open the place you
have come to has an extraordinary number
of powerful treasures unique charismatic
things and like you they come from all
parts of the world some of them are in
the by Nicki library where presidents a
lavey and I along with our spouses will
greet you later this morning more of
them are in our amazing art and natural
history museums in our collection of
rare musical instruments and in our
libraries let them become part of you
and let discovery guide your life and so
I close by saying to you class of 2017
open your arms open your eyes embrace
seeing embrace learning